okay bet yourself a [ __ ] back okay
okay um anyways it's been a [ __ ]
while I hope I still know how to play
this game it's been like a week I can't
tell you yeah well I can tell you I can
I can
and it has everyone's Alan I've been I
using the usual solemn things to survive
I like eating things off the street but
deep down I bet I like it I like it
so that's okay that's gone out here
okay good once things get as bad as they
probably are your only option is to
escape good okay uh I got an eye patch
and I'm kind of just a tiny bit better
ah okay because I think the last time I
saved it and I yeah I said I saved the
game when I just looked but my tie but
further but yeah so I'm like this [ __ ]
and I guess oh say what's going on
better
[Music]
your sister naked am i rolling over kids
I get my computer I still remember when
you ruined my collector conquistador
save files I broke your arm when I found
out I regret that now but a [ __ ] death
part of you messing with my stuff
okay luckily I got the pass rush it all
the way caricature and I'm a master
hacker oh [ __ ] okay okay a day okay and
then the finale's a bucket [ __ ] and
that's an hour [ __ ] I'm just like a
master hacker not [ __ ]
the next add Brad why not why not I
guess [ __ ] you bet this statue is worth
a lot of money Morgan I'm going to be
charitable and assume you scuffled with
a - and just break it out of spy file no
chance - thank you and a mess rogue
operator and I think yeah I guess we're
operators mine I took
fitness ties yeah
personality Jeff yeah okay anyways this
is where I gotta get I think I've went
in there and saved metals it chef
[ __ ] do this again okay come on
how did I do this again I think I
[ __ ] wedge to [ __ ] it come on come on
oh yeah there we go there we go okay
excuse me okay
I always hack every time I'm a [ __ ]
hack afraid okay I guess I guess yes
they say like stealing candy from a cell
barn baby bang and I think this one is
bad as they probably are your only
option is to escape I now then you get
the word about what's happening on tell
us one Alex has a private escape pod
it's locked up I made a copy of the key
and hit it on top of the data tower near
the near you know the one I'm talking
about as a car in a tent there's more to
take this time than just us or this
station and I love that is just one of
those creatures made it back home then
we're lost
thank you having this dream I'm just
staring into the black between the stars
there's something there shut that fat
guy mattress
I just can't edit that but it sees me
I can feel it hat house any other store
I know you know what I'm talking about
what is that I got you a tie let's go I
mean not a table well shut oh wow
nothing anything else here Oh quick as I
can
again all right I guess I can
how you'd ELPS you tracking bracelet did
I always have a coalition and nothing to
do that please don't be far
okay thank you they're like psychobabble
then to your mind
[ __ ] nuts okay can I get in here I
thought I'd [ __ ] have the matching
key card the [ __ ] do I need I think I
think it's not I guess a little continue
look up to you how do I get down from
here
yeah yes I like this mess there's that
all right shout out here I gotta [ __ ] it
time is money time to funny okay so
buddy what is my mission and two
quarters move
crew quarters and it's out of sight for
me
okay chat
I'll walk in this game actually thought
that much walking a lot of a lot of Yuna
cut stops it's gone here
a hack at I should be a little [ __ ]
hack anything I [ __ ] like level
twenty clearance I got the area master
yeah mmm my [ __ ] eyes are dry holy
[ __ ]
it's all I got right there I hate right
I just say that right now if you're
going to rape someone like oh you know I
got person yes I am sure [ __ ]
alright Kirk waters alright let's see
what everyone got come on come on
shut you I see you and the puppet
looking for me with black eggs behind
your eyes come closer
[Music]
stupid puppet what you do you want to
come into the kitchen
come and get me can you the [ __ ] is
going on over there
vital signs critical what the [ __ ] was
that
whether you're gay you can't fight it
these boys as I get out disrupter stun
gun now what the [ __ ] is does can it go
far
what is this not I guess stupid bees you
think it can't kill me with pants just
cuz of my side that he's not just like
crazy
wait did it say use whoever you all run
there is no more for you
except you if you are still ahold of
your brain good others here
I'm not shoot bug before they get close
Oh private [ __ ] mom then master school
to pick a purpose so both of you again
or even have anything to kill us
and kill you well no more puppets maybe
we talk shaaka [ __ ] I got like no
[ __ ] ammo
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] was that
[Music]
okay glue do this Oh puppet so both but
do it before they kill you when you're
more topics maybe we talk okay okay come
on [ __ ] come on this way
Oh what the [ __ ] is that like sigh
energy [ __ ] that he just [ __ ] did
that's what killed me loose okay here we
go I'll pop it so both but do it before
they kill you well no more prophets
maybe we talk
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] okay
I'm coming back to this guy whoo
give this a puppet so both like that you
said before they kill you when no more
profits maybe we stop a bad back okay
once I any it's understood an iron
bracket like yeah guy [ __ ] can't eat
that now no no should I could eat
shut any Sheraton what the [ __ ] is that
okay Wow
to get the executive suite get the [ __ ]
in is a [ __ ] okay don't worry I'm a
thank God hacking is like a [ __ ] best
one yet [ __ ] getting stuff
baby
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
no oxygens air graphing I got five I
can't rely on Morgan's my wrist wow this
is like my actual room that's cool
memory logs
Calvino colleague will notice anything
wrong eidetic memory
work-obsessed perfect medical record no
absences new entry show Danielle
head of IT this likes you it's like that
I find out why I owe you one axe hires
Alex desires cheap to recruit through
their was unpopular stance on psychic
phenomena all of the station's best
scientists how actually later lucien
chief engineer not on speaking terms had
brief relationship you ended it when
tests began she believes it is because
you discovered her medical condition
para plexus convenience with false care
plexus nerve disorder prevents use of
neurons requires aggressive drug their
Sara Eleazar chief of security not
afraid to [ __ ] that and now that
what's that the [ __ ] is that let me say
what is this one all right yeah this
what is this an Eightball
Pizza okay let's say I got a gen cockin
and I can't you better not thank you
last time this was like a [ __ ] mirror
I should need a [ __ ] H at this rice
cooker and I'll talk in a chit op I have
to let me see what else I have
we made this bench now that was in the
game Monday yep
each other trashcan how do you [ __ ] I
need to get to eat my [ __ ] guys like
dying I have any [ __ ] like health
kits in here I guess this is all they
ask sad it's up there no way oh [ __ ]
[Music]
where is he oh shut and then [ __ ] it bet
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] now I'm definitely
going to steal all this [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
toilet now push not that we disgusting
so if I drink this do I get help
yeah a little help
I had our describe a kitchen no where
does this guy [ __ ] get food from only
missing over here
I guess this guy's tears had to get a
kitchen very sad okay Alex would use
room this guy has to get [ __ ] he's
technically tonight holy [ __ ] that
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me oh
[ __ ] I jumped on that even though I felt
[ __ ] shake it yeah
my nan Madol [ __ ] not again okay okay
no chef
can i Rama
nice nice okay this is where I started
looking for [ __ ] food expresso
nothing yeah
where's the [ __ ] food in this guy
just to kind of Spanish [ __ ] don't tell
me there's no food in here [ __ ] salad
is [ __ ] my gram [ __ ] high shut up
okay check this I check this [ __ ]
that get that out of my face
I'm going to pretty much jealousy folks
pretty sad oh [ __ ] okay give me your
[ __ ] emails Kayla
not that you okay so like I thought
there was a good [ __ ] here that what is
this guy dad time I bet there's that
time Oh what is this thank you go that's
what we're that's what we need it I kept
talking like ooh quarters
Daniel show back and fast
[Music]
to bring mostly Hannah again so [ __ ]
loud I can't even think
Norma's okay what do I need help now
that idea and then two additional
chipsets Becca engineer my fridge ya
Dums left yeah panda suit mozz man this
male there terral's mop tack wrench -
curious what I need
salmon on there
speed up that nip when I write at 150
who
Danny like God focus security opens okay
that's all right
all right there another way around there
okay [ __ ] that yes
[Music]
maybe I could go this way and then up
crew captains okay good
[Music]
Gary what happened hey out justify got
that jet charge okay okay then we there
should be no enemies here
[ __ ] Candice have to shut
holy [ __ ] Wow
[ __ ] you [ __ ] okay here's a man okay
Oh like scat
[Music]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] thinks he's like the
boss of it all right des I'll [ __ ] the
whole bunch of them okay what's up [ __ ]
can I like [ __ ]
[Music]
so [ __ ] is that what is this and I die
by a hat huh yeah I'll take this I guess
error I respect that [ __ ]
little did you know I was a master
hacker in my college patch oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
yep
a mouse ball shot okay can I eat this
anything behind that
no nothing more [ __ ] in here was that
[ __ ] out so I drank it
what was the point to be in his room
nothing a heads on that look I need more
key cards isn't here what's the bathroom
bad [ __ ] where is that [ __ ]
dancing what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] where are they
and that let's go
[Applause]
okay right almost struggle busted a
[ __ ] load this [ __ ] up
where's the mimic
and I say masala
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't want to do that okay [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay I need like weapon I need like
[ __ ] ammo okay
well there's that nice what is it like
horrifying eyes
okay dad
you can hear something
Oh
what is it like noise
I sent about Nana
[Music]
okay [ __ ] eat
okay there's a [ __ ] in here okay
[Applause]
[ __ ] horse
where is it I got [ __ ]
that's not psychobabble place again they
don't just sound of serious so I wanted
to shut my transcribe off so okay so
you're asking me if it's okay to record
our game on the transcribe yes I know
using the memory it's not right I can't
be having this conversation oh I'm so
sorry I'm gonna lose my job for even
talking to you about this what what look
exactly what you're going to do is have
dinner with me what you say what a lot
when you should say yes okay what is
this kind of like that right
see also don't worry about the
transcribes it's not against regulation
what is that oh are you gonna invite me
to this game or not what you're doing
are you recording this joint transcribes
are fun they are not it's like mental
scrapbooking you both save something the
matter
okay
cavitation pods go [ __ ] up an act
okay you know there's some [ __ ] going on
in here what is that
[ __ ] this is scary okay
where's that noise
and when I say that's squashing nice
okay I don't know what that is about
what the [ __ ] was that
oh [ __ ] it [ __ ] where is it look at it
trying to get away
welcome to Phil I bet did I kill it
where is it where is it
oh you [ __ ] got me with the [ __ ]
chair you think that's not cool I
actually gonna take a piss lot for this
one
yeah I got tip [ __ ]
Holly [ __ ] okay you're [ __ ] good in
this shot
right ahead of [ __ ] you
okay they're going to eat something
anything I can eat real quick
officer files will you have an important
request it's sensitive though I need to
know I can trust you with faithlyn's
manner uh yes of course sir it's just
that normally I can't decide 1 6 7 9
al azhar a Chuck part and another
director those people over part to me oh
yeah
yes sir I understand I want you to keep
an eye on annalisa hey guys where's she
goes now she keeps visitors
I'll log everything on the security
computer good some of your report idea
in a week yes sir I wanted to check in
on you Skye just a neuro mod hangover I
feel weird I can't believe you got
modded for Alex's clown show at the
tulip are you kidding
I've always wanted to play an instrument
but never have a time so it's like I can
see the sheet music in my head I feel
like I've been doing this since I was
seven besides you are going to be on
stage with very good only to catch you
if you suddenly collapse and only if you
keep me from punching Alex if I drink
too much
what does objective do I have right here
of a lot with some water now thank you
okay that I get the key to anything in
here real quick what it says yeah right
now
don't recycle atrocities as a weapon
there we go
hey guys watch SI logo and just watch us
a little bit shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] come
on Omar Omar okay
okay guys
is that they are at no thanks I'm not
getting okay okay
[ __ ] lot of ammo here holy [ __ ] this is
a far one oh god oh god I'm running out
of time okay set got a meltdown
okay shut okay okay okay okay okay
[Music]
I closed the doors from that [ __ ] I
can't okay I got to be fast
[ __ ] it
get my vital signs critical the [ __ ] was
that what was that
[ __ ] did I don't see what the [ __ ] that
was okay don't like a suit repair kit
all that [ __ ] cubing sells caviar
shotgun shell that's like a [ __ ] eat
soup repair kit circuit board alright
and I think oh [ __ ]
take oh yeah it take yeah
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
where's my where's Mike structor
and they say I shouldn't be drinking but
blimey
[ __ ] I don't even have [ __ ]
[ __ ] it ah trying to reach Abby but
she's not answering
please wait what is that
yeah I can barely hear you say is Abby
with you
are you okay yes not me it's not I want
I want go on do it
you can okay [ __ ] savings I'm gonna
see if anything good here and I think
you're poor in here what Bible sighs now
what the [ __ ] is he doing Buffy killed
me you can see this anything nice in
here
yep definitely know you out [ __ ]
well that was really not worth it yes
Chazz are hot okay
that's the point of that set by the song
now [ __ ] it yeah okay
[ __ ] was that what is that noise
concierge is that I need thank God
what is that noise medical day is right
behind me that is exactly why I need to
be okay get in the kitchen and [ __ ] in
the pool but there's a fabric and get
your [ __ ] oh my god and I'm recording
insane a setup it's pretty weird Quinton
I know but if I'm I don't want to know
I'm doing this as a favor that's all
cargo container three two three two it's
only the other side of cargo bay be next
to this utility gun when I was head chef
at peace Institute
no one asked me to conceal food in a
cargo container just go easy on a deal
alright alright
I haven't oh [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] right
there that's the one where this before
okay
okay at one six seven nine okay close
this section sucks today yeah oh thank
the Lord heaven thank the Lord
the light is gone the Lord giveth and
the Lord taketh okay but isn't there
like a [ __ ] yes a medical okay okay
the pair of the medical bag should be
right here
yeah gotta be [ __ ] kidding me oh
what's in here
I thank I like and I like FF and that
life-taker yes medical operators [ __ ]
goat okay I get for two inspired
positive negative me eat this now take
some [ __ ] space I can't [ __ ] sucks
okay wait because I always able to do
that by just drawing [ __ ] out of shut up
[ __ ]
maybe he'll I like Lila days operator
operator quinonoid you diagnosed thing
okay
we are going to [ __ ] that [ __ ] up now
oh there's a secret over here now
[ __ ] it up there
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh you're running huh
all right bet ya [ __ ] [ __ ] an egg
[Music]
ah you you profit now you join them you
compulsion window let me see
Oh like Kelly fetches first I'm a
[ __ ] Ted okay where's the kitchen one
down [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god wait to meet
objectives gone on now [ __ ]
this one I got
[ __ ] kitchen got that food right yeah
you know ask you what is in your name
tab you hmm and you and you you kill
this yourself huh if you want to come in
this safe you go get something of mine
huh right here key it opens my room go
there get my award it's important to me
then maybe we talk [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
any further and the cafetaria
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on it [ __ ] I
needed this it's wrong you [ __ ]
mimics okay no no I don't need that
okay well can I just a CAC my way in let
me say nein ich ich are fine okay sighs
[ __ ]
yeah he took all the [ __ ] food a hot
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] it suddenly turn oh good
to see you again dr. Hugh diagnosed yes
operation okay
straight on the Rex I will get that [ __ ]
real quickly to scores go away about our
flickering station is just hurting keep
going
[ __ ] in there
what's his award Oh minimal shuffleboard
set I'm under this banana peel
what the hell did you do to that thing
Mitchell
sounds like an auntie waffle commercial
well I didn't see it as an override
perfect share what the [ __ ] it enables
the station sequencer
they're usually supreme do you know how
many security protocols you broke well
Morgan said it was alright even helped
me this is an AP conversation skillet
yeah he's still alive uh yeah uh-huh
what is mu comes back let them you in
but but what you finding you got the
window show me
heck you found something huh
have to let you in promise
go around the side entrance okay wait a
minute
[Music]
you're safe now
the beasts they cannot get in but look
at this we have food but no water
this pressure glitter it is broken epic
that system of the money kind of until
fixed eel six smart one
here I open freezer now let the promised
lots of get trapped and supplies okay
all right dump this
any lies of fit Matt that's it huh and
you know n-no way I really need this I
already hear this name before quiet
now eat is this guy gonna murder me Oh
saving here
what's up Clark ah okay Chuck are you
awake um you frozen dead maybe I take
puppets toy scream I see all the names
in a list your name to means you listen
from now on I know who are em you son of
William you William trust are always
playing with lies now maybe I watch this
piece each like you trying to feed me to
them more cold kills you first make
using to a frozen puppet I'm still in
deep storage I don't know why you won't
pick up I hope you're safe if things get
bad I'm all tense in a data falls and
space walk along the hall come to the
fitness center and bang on the window
but you shouldn't feel the vibration
Abby please don't take any chances all
right I'd be safe
okay what's in here
holy [ __ ] there's a good shirt in here I
get hot I gotta get rid of this [ __ ]
EMP charge no thank you
transfer antara not back yet transfer
then I have to thank you
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
wow this so dope okay
[ __ ]
stuff like this poly shield get freeze
in here and I [ __ ]
okay so I'll find out
suspicious me what the [ __ ]
chaos crab okay well I need all the
[ __ ] food I could get so what else am
i losing here yeah yes tank now thank
you I'm not really so much of an ill
person as you are come on get out of
here come on [ __ ] hike
okay and I want to service but I guess
I'll ask Bakken
ready go
all right Joey I service the [ __ ]
Syrian here Tom why can't I get what is
that
what the [ __ ] am I missing
try and make a medkit I guess how many
can I do
[Music]
go [ __ ] is it what tristar chunk not go
off mu maybe you see avoid it alright I
guess we go to the rec center alright
what is that noise [ __ ] is that noise
now this rec center over there
this is weird hey Brett that honey hi
Daddy
happy birthday I made you a present but
you'll have to open it on and get home
because your company has blame rules
guess what
I finally trotted with Lita it was
awesome um what else
Oh Ren feeding on your cowboy boots
sorry I really miss you
tell mr. Yu I said kids should be
allowed in space well I guess that's all
for now I love you okay what objectives
I turn off
okay
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was that
is that a safe car that's Billy okay
okay obviously there's something going
on here I need a [ __ ] rich
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] bet now
tracking your alien material detected
cheese's
okay and the fitness center is where
everything was [ __ ] going down loving
it yeah one of these things could change
the game now that's for sure in the
center window
okay
that's get any act
[Music]
and kak Kellen upstairs now
holy [ __ ]
now now now okay okay and the Sun we are
one in the Sun wait
okay guys nothing
let's bet saw Mack
that's not charming
Oh shet okay Jesus uses care BAM again
viral songs yeah a [ __ ] load a game
why not [ __ ] dying
okay are we good good
yeah dad dad
step leg on up yeah
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] ahead
my head
integrity - back at Sun it's a chef that
I got it bro I got it just keep down
watch it done it [ __ ] die really
with the [ __ ] people
okay especially gonna die Morgan if
you're here then Abby didn't make it yes
[ __ ] I make it now I don't I can help I
know you need to get into deep storage i
boy swapped it but I have the override
that bypasses the random Ward input set
your transcribe to record all right Alex
Oedipus complex pompous Navitus no
offense to your brother but that should
be enough but what's your step there's
someone else in crew quarters pretending
to be the cook his tracking bracelets
from psychotronics but the ID doesn't
make any sense he I think he's the one
that killed Abby Maryland can make sure
he doesn't get off the station I'll see
what else I can do to help from out here
here as long as I can good bye Marcus
hey [ __ ]
this is the big alien right
I already like [ __ ] did the cup
well done find your chief show you've
got what you need to get into deep
storage shut the [ __ ] up
okay
ah [ __ ]
hi Kel the impostor cook say hey where'd
it go all right well let me just uh can
I get healed okay oh good you again dr.
Yoo na ma Li I know things look like you
had a rough day I'll have you feeling
okay can I get this helping up a [ __ ]
9:00 or Ahmad
[Music]
they're all better
I need a suit repair can right please
fill out a patient experience questions
or [ __ ] you some Nile and now
[Music]
and there so I can serve you better next
okay let me just check out this [ __ ]
let me go back to the cook and see if I
can see him let a think this [ __ ] one
usual win he's much emotional where
question is I can go
ah this catches right here where the
[ __ ] to cook laughs well I guess a lot
of episode that okay guys I gave
watching bad yeah